[Musique]
vendredi la semaine c'est benhaim et le
vendredi c'est moi merci beaucoup merci
pour la semaine dernière aussi un on a
retrouvé la plage de biloxi empty merci
ça me fait très plaisir ça me fait chaud
au coeur
et puis espagne est rejeté tout en vrai
que physiquement ça va beaucoup mieux
voilà j'ai retrouvé cette place le lidl
physique aussi la demande est là le
public est là merci beaucoup
adam mair un tout petit mot passe
quelque chose qu'on déteste dans cette
émission se faire du mal aux gens on
aime bien rigoler on aime bien se moquer
de nous surtout et la semaine dernière
on a fait un débat sur destination
eurovision a parlé de bilal hassani et
puis on a eu un petit mot malheureux
tous en en parlant notamment catherine
mais évidemment c'était pas fait exprès
qui a utilisé le mot travestis à un
moment donné c'était va là pas du tout
dans ce qu tout ce qu'on aime et
lorsqu'on voulait dire je l'aï eu au
téléphone j'ai présenté mes excuses mais
je lui ai dit que quand on était une
bêtise en public qu'il fallait s'excuser
en public c'est ce que je voulais faire
mon émission aujourd'hui
et puis voilà et qu'il est bien un tout
petit mot catherine non vérifié
je suis pragmatique si je blesse je
m'excuse pardon pour cette phrase qui
n'étaient en rien homophobes
trèbes la spirale
[Applaudissements]